more than 150 kids nationwide are now
confirmed to have a mystery illness that
may be linked to the virus or lead
national correspondent David beg know is
following the story we're now dealing
with an issue that's very disturbing the
governor of New York Andrew Cuomo says
state health officials are investigating
about 100 cases of pediatric
multi-system inflammatory syndrome the
condition can affect the blood vessels
and organs and cause high fever and
dangerously low blood pressure it's no
time to get cocky no time to get
arrogant this virus has deceived us
every step of the way even as new
questions arise about the corona virus
governors are pushing ahead with plans
to reopen in California Governor Gavin
Newsom is urging caution after
announcing new rules for dining
restaurants in parts of the state none
of this means anything if customers
don't feel safe it's true that
coronavirus cases are falling in many of
the hardest hit areas but an unreleased
FEMA report finds that corona virus
infection rates in some cities spiked
dramatically in early May after many
states loosened restrictions take
Nashville and Des Moines cases increased
by more than 90 percent over 7 days and
new hot spots continue to spike at
meatpacking plants in the Midwest 212
new cases were found at Tysons Madison
Nebraska pork plant and in Saint Cloud
Minnesota the pilgrims pride poultry
processing plant saw cases more than
double from 83 on Friday to 194 monday
workers protested including Mohammed
Burrell walking off the job he spoke
through a translator we are demanding
the company to close down and they work
less and do I must testing and open
again let me read you a statement from
pilgrims pride they say the processing
plant the health and safety of our team
members remains our highest priority and
we have implemented a wide range of
measures to combat the corona virus we
know some people are scared and anxious
and we're doing everything we can to
keep the virus out of the facility as
for the plant in Madison Nebraska Tyson
says it shut that location down for a
deep cleaning last week and it's
screening its employees daily including
checking their temperature Gayle all
right David thank you very much